الاوضاع هنا في جنوب الخرطوم في هذا السوق
تبدو وكانها عاديه يحاول المواطن الان
الاستفاده من الهدنه وفي نفس الوقت
التعايش مع الوضع خاصه وان اللافته اليوم
في هذا السوق هنالك انخفاض في الاسعار
لربما بوفره المعروض من هذه المنتجات او
لربما بقله السيوله في هذه في هذه في هذا
السوق ولكن يمكننا معرفه هذه الاسباب
يعني اليوم ما هو الذي لفت نظرك في هذا
السوق والله اليوم السوق الوضع من جدا جدا
وما شاء الله كلها شغاله والسوق شغال
وسفريات شغاله والوضع في الاقلام ما شاء
الله كويس الاسعار الاسعار والله مناسبه
مناسبه جدا كل الطماطم ب400 وكيلو البطاطس
ب 300 ولا عندنا الاسعار لعليه شديد ولا
منخفضه شديد وسط اسعار كويسه يعني قبل
يومين كان هنالك ارتفاع في الاسعار بسبب
ربما ندره المعروض او بسبب يعني التراب
وكذلك الرغبه الكبيره للمواطنين للحصول
على احتياجاتهم ولكن اليوم يمكننا هذا احد
المواطنين ايضا يعني ياخذ اغراضه يستفيد
من الهدنه معه خبز وكذلك بعض الاقراض كيف
وجدت السوق وما هي كيف الاسعار والله
الحمد لله اليوم كويسه والله حقيقه يعني
يعني
بالف ونصف يعني في انفراج واضح والله حتى
الخبز يعني الخبز انا وقفت هسه يعني زمن
وجيزه اخذت خبز تشاهدون لان العدد من
المواطنين يقفون امام هذا المخبز للحصول
على
احتياجاتهم وكذلك يعني كيف الوضع الان
المواطن يستفيد من الهدنه عشان كثير من
احتياجاته ويرجع كيف تعيشتم مع هذه
الاوضاع نعم الاوضاع عندنا هنا في
الكلاكله نحمد الله يعني من بدايه
الاشتباكات والاوضاع هذه تماما ليس هناك
اي تفلتات والسبب لانه لا توجد اي معسكرات
او اي تجمع عسكري في هذه المنطقه او او
حواليها يعني الا معسكر طيبه وهو بعيد
يبعد كل البعد عن هذه المنطقه هذا جزء من
الانتباعات المواطنين في ظل هذه الهدنه
الذين يحاولون يعني الحصول على احتياجاتهم
من المواد الغذائيه وغيرها يعني وان كانت
هنالك انخفاض في الاسعار في الخضر ولكن
البعض يعزوه لكثره العرض وشحال السيوله
والبعض الاخر يرى ان هنالك يعني يعني
انتهى او المواطن استطاع ان يمتص الصدمه
الاولى ويتعايش مع الاوضاع وان كانت هنالك
ما تزال بعض الازمات والحياه يعني يصيب ها
الشلل بسبب